au procès de patrick dils devant la cour
d'assises dès mineurs du rhône journée
difficile pour l'accusé au sa position a
été confrontée à celle du magistrat qui
a instruit la faire il ya maintenant 15
ans sur place dominique verdeilhan et
patrick decker
quinze ans plus tard le juge n'a pas
oublié les aveux de patrick 10
j'étais sidéré cela faisait froid dans
le dos dans son bureau deal ça parlait
calmement longuement sans émotion d'une
manière réfléchie
lors de la reconstitution précise le
magistrat patrick dils a refait les
gestes
un détail près troublant il n'a par
situer le lieu exact des cris mais à
l'audience le greffier gérard mathis cas
évoque la comparution de deals devant le
juge
j'en ai encore la chair de poule deal
c'était ni terrorisé ni traumatisé bien
au contraire ils se libéraient il
parlait librement avec cohérence
mauvaise journée mauvaise semaine pour
patrick 10 il demeure néanmoins un
malaise après l'audition des policiers
des magistrats des erreurs des légèretés
désuni seul a donc compté la religion de
l'aveu ce procès certes celui du
mensonge
seulement voilà qui ment